[Music]
on this Wednesday night Canada's fiscal
snapshot we took on debt so Canadians
wouldn't have to the deficit now pegged
at a massive three hundred and forty
three billion dollars it's gonna be all
of our challenge we're gonna work on
that our one on one with the finance
minister pressure from the US president
his push to get kids back in class I
think it is logistical II legitimately
impossible ending racial profiling the
plan from Montreal police and why
critics are skeptical and buckling under
when a bridge just can't take the wait
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
we know the pandemic has been a massive
economic shock now we have a snapshot of
just how massive it's the worst picture
since the end of the Second World War
the federal deficit is now projected to
be 343 billion dollars
compare that to last fall before the
pandemic the projected deficit then was
just 34 billion and the national debt is
expected to exceed 1 trillion dollars
for the first time in Canadian history
about a third of the workforce is
without jobs Prime Minister Justin
Trudeau says Canada is in a strong
position to bounce back as a federal
government given the historically low
interest rates and the low debt
servicing costs that we have and given
our extremely strong fiscal position
going in we decided to take on that debt
to prevent Canadians from having to do
it our chief political correspondent
David akin has looked through the
numbers of this fiscal snapshot David
what's the bottom line here well Donna
there's no sugarcoating this the deficit
this year is going to be ginormous ten
times the size of last year's deficit a
tidal wave of red ink when you look at
the scale of our of our support it's 14
percent of our GDP a very significant
response that we know is going to help
us to get through this particularly
challenging time Finance Minister Bill
Morneau says the deficit this year will
be just over three hundred and forty
three billion dollars that's ten times
bigger than last year's deficit of
thirty-four point four billion in
relative terms the deficit will clock in
this year at nearly 16 percent of the
size of Canada's economy versus just 1.5
percent last year
Canada enjoys an extraordinarily good
credit rating and the demand for
Canadian securities for government debt
it remains very strong so I don't think
we're really looking at that in terms of
it being a crisis or a signal that we're
in really dire straits the economy will
likely shrink this year by about seven
percent but a dark warning if a second
wave of kovat 19 comes back and
horses more lockdowns the economy could
shrink by 14% and that would be about as
bad as the worst year in the Great
Depression 1930 when the economy shrank
by 15% looking ahead the government is
signaling some changes are coming to the
Canada emergency wage subsidy but other
than that the document is silent on the
Future past this year no path to a
balanced budget no word if key
government services will be cut enhanced
or modified and there are no changes to
tax rates up or down we can give the
government a pat on the back for what
they've done but we're not there yet
and there's a lot more to come now one
quirk of the times with interest rates
so low the federal government will
actually pay less this year on interest
charges than last year and think about
that with the debt hitting a trillion
dollars the federal government will
actually pay four billion dollars less
in interest Donna thank goodness for low
interest rates David akin and Ottawa
thanks let's go to our Ottawa bureau
chief Mercedes Stevenson Mercedes this
is a snapshot not a full picture
the opposition parties wanted more what
do they say is missing from it well
Donna the Conservatives and the NDP come
at this from very different angles as
you can imagine but here's a place where
they have common ground on what's
missing from this fiscal snapshot
opposition parties are saying there is
no plan for how the government will
continue to support Canadian households
and businesses as this pandemic
stretches on and on and that it does not
lay out a roadmap to recovery or any
specifics on how the government will pay
for the billions of dollars they've
already spent and how many are going to
be spent going forward the Conservatives
want more money for businesses the NDP
say not enough is being done to help
vulnerable Canadians here's some of what
Andrew Shearer and jug meat Singh had to
say today for the first time ever this
year the net federal debt will reach
over one trillion dollars in fact
they're boring so much money mr. speaker
that the Bank of Canada has to create it
out of thin air so he asked the
government
to put in place a wealth tax on those
who have fortunes of over 20 million
dollars let's ask the wealthiest to bear
the brunt of the pandemic Mercedes
budgets and fiscal updates are always
political documents as much as financial
ones what are some of this government's
political calculations right now well
Donna there's two separate calculations
the government has to make on the one
hand maintaining power in Parliament
they're a minority government so they
have to find ways to keep opposition
parties happy so far they've been
leaning towards the left and more
spending there but they all still have
to make Canadians feel that they have
their back and will support them if they
want to win the next election Donna all
right Mercedes Stevenson in Ottawa thank
you and a little later I'll ask the
finance minister about those missing
pieces from the opposition about his
plan for the path forward and how we
have to learn to live with this pandemic
meantime Via Rail is struggling to cope
with reduced demand for travel and plans
now to temporarily lay off 1,000
employees the montreal based company
says the layoffs will take effect on
July 24th it hopes the move will offset
the pandemics increasing financial blows
the same number of vea employees were
temporarily laid off in February because
of the rail blockades the federal
conservative leader is asked today about
those pictures on social media from
Toronto's Pearson International Airport
Andrew Shira and Manitoba premier Brian
Pallister were photographed sitting in
the departures area on Tuesday at that
moment neither was wearing a mask masks
are mandatory for all passengers and
staff at Pearson Airport Shearer says he
took his off to take a call and he added
this when asked about it today I think
the picture is pretty self-explanatory I
think my my answer yesterday was pretty
self-explanatory as well and if you want
to go like analyze social media pictures
if you're looking for some kind of
approver film to break down frame by
frame I think that's pretty ridiculous
premier Pallister says he made a mistake
when he took his mask off and says it
won't happen again in Edmonton the
Misericordia Hospital has now closed its
doors to new patients and canceled all
surgeries
because of an outbreak of kovat 19 it's
described as a full facility outbreak
and extends to all adult and child
services including the emergency
department 20 patients and 15 staff have
tested positive for the virus three
patients linked to the outbreak have
died cases have steadily increased at
the hospital since the outbreak first
began on June 20th there's a new picture
of how Canada is coping with the
pandemic federal modeling released today
shows by July 17th the predicted number
of cases would be between about a
hundred and six thousand cases in just
over 111,000 we are roughly in that zone
right now Canada's chief public health
officer says transmission is largely
under control in most parts of the
country these dynamic models all tell us
that if we relax
too much or too soon the epidemic will
most likely rebound with explosive
growth as a distinct possibility this
possibility of significant resurgence is
not just hypothetical as this is exactly
what we are already seeing in some other
parts of the world and that includes the
United States where President Donald
Trump is putting pressure on governors
now to send kids back to school as coded
19 outbreaks spiked more than three
million Americans have tested positive
and that's nearly a quarter of all cases
globally 60,000 new cases were reported
in the US yesterday that's the highest
single day spike yet outbreaks in three
states are now worse than any other
country in the world when you look at
the number of cases per million people
over the past seven days Arizona takes
top spot followed by Florida and South
Carolina as Jackson prosecco explains
President Trump is determined to get
back to business
more than 50 ICUs in Florida have
reached capacity in parts of Texas one
in every four COBIT 19 tests comes back
positive in the next two weeks we're
currently gonna end up being what New
York was two months ago despite those
dire warnings the rapid spread of the
virus across America is still being
downplayed by President Donald Trump
well I think we are in a good place as
they did with businesses the White House
is now pushing schools to reopen on an
aggressive timeline with Trump making
the mostly empty threat to withhold
federal funding if they don't they must
fully open and they must be fully
operational the Trump administration has
gone so far as to attack the advice from
its own Centers for Disease Control
claiming school reopening guidelines are
too tough we don't want the guidance
from CDC to be a reason why schools
don't open New York has said it will
reopen under a hybrid model welcoming
students back on alternating days to
reduce crowding other hotspots may be
hard-pressed to bring anyone back for
fear students will spread the virus to
teachers and bring it home to their
parents we have to think about schools
in the same way that we've thought about
every other workplace and every other
environment for play and for social
environment and then say to ourselves
fundamentally it's really unlikely all
of this assumes that parents want to
send their children back just as it
called for all schools to reopen the
White House Task Force told Americans
living in current hotspots to stay home
is really asking the American people in
those counties and in those days in
those states to not only use the face
coverings not going to bar is not going
to indoor dining but really not
gathering in homes either the result
more confusion about what's safe and
what's not at a time when there's no
doubt about the terrifying trajectory of
the pandemic in the US
Jackson prosto Global News Washington
President Donald Trump signed the new
NAFTA deal at the White House today and
only the President of Mexico was with
him the agreement took more than two
years to negotiate even though it's been
ratified by all three nations there are
a number of outstanding issues and Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau opted not to
cross the border for the
photo op he hailed the signing though as
a success for all three nations he says
he's concerned about the lingering
threat of US tariffs on Canadian
aluminum and steel the United States
relies heavily on imports of Canadian
aluminum in particular for their
domestic manufacturing capacity the US
doesn't make nearly enough aluminum to
be able to cover its needs particularly
at a time where we want the economies to
get going again the prime minister says
there is no justification for levying
new tariffs the NDP leader jug meets
Singh calls the incident at Rideau Hall
last week domestic terrorism an armed
man is accused of ramming the gates with
his truck he was eventually taken into
custody and charged with threatening to
cause death or bodily harm to the Prime
Minister Singh says if the intruder had
been a person of color the outcome would
have been different
Singh compared the way that incident was
handled to that of ejs Chaudhary the 62
year old Ontario man who was shot and
killed by police during a mental-health
call someone showed up to potentially
kill the Prime Minister of Canada or
with weapons at his residence and that
person was arrested without any violence
and you had a person in his own home was
killed that to me is what systemic
racism in policing is all about that
difference 46 year old Cory her and a
member of the Canadian Armed Forces was
arrested without incident on July 2nd
after police spent several hours talking
to him he's facing 22 criminal charges
including firearms offenses and making
that threat against the prime minister
keeping Street checks in check coming up
the Montreal police plan to end racial
profiling
racial profiling when authorities
suspect a person because of the way they
look or the color of their skin should
not be happening anymore but we know it
does including in Canada
critics say too often black and
indigenous people are targeted now for
the first time Montreal is adopting a
new policy on police Street checks Mike
Armstrong explains what it is and
whether it's enough the goal of the new
policy according to Montreal police
chief is to take discrimination off the
table
going forward his officers will only be
able to stop people based on what they
see happening rather than who that
person is you look at his high gunman
chiefs Ivanka Hall says he recognizes
systemic racism and how it has led to
disparities in police checks
well those disparities are considerable
a report by independent researchers last
fall found black people and indigenous
people in Montreal were four to five
times more likely to be stopped by
police than white people
the new policy doesn't really change the
interaction what it does is say
explicitly things like ethnicity gender
or sexual preference can't be the reason
people are being checked the policy also
mandates officers log each interaction
including why the person was stopped and
their ethnic background so the citizen
when he wants to complaint there's a
basis now on the way that the police
officer has to work there are Canadian
jurisdictions that have gone further
Nova Scotia just last fall banned Street
checks that came after a report in
Halifax found black people were six
times more likely than white people to
be stopped
the Toronto new rules were brought in in
2016 and carding almost completely
disappeared Street checks in Toronto
dropped from hundreds of thousands each
year to just one in 2018 while critics
say Montreal dragged its feet and should
have gone further in fact some question
whether Montreal officers will fill out
forms on their Street checks at the end
of the day are they actually going to do
it there's also concerned that the
policy doesn't have teeth what the
public should know is when they are
intercepted and it is discriminatory
what are the sanctions in place and how
are they going to be
did Jessica feel the chief does say the
policy isn't set in stone
there will be an independent review in
2021 and if there's still a problem
promises the policy will change my car
from global news Montreal a new report
from the Auditor General raises
questions about how the Canada Border
Services Agency handles foreign
nationals the report done this spring
found the CBSA lost track of thirty four
thousand seven hundred people who were
supposed to leave the country
it says the agency has failed to
promptly remove most of the people
ordered to leave the Auditor General
found the CBSA had not touched thousands
of files for years including some
high-priority removals the report also
flagged several other issues including
poor data collection case management
flaws and problems sharing information
with immigration officials still ahead
an exclusive snapshot with the Finance
Minister Bill Morneau
welcome back Canada's finance minister
says the pandemic has been an enormous
shock to our system and his fiscal
snapshot today painted a pretty grim
picture mr. Morneau joins me now from
Ottawa Minister thanks for taking time
for us Canadians are looking for some
hope now and for a plan how long do
people need to be patient with this
economic uncertainty and and worried
about their financial future I think
that what was most important for us
today was to give Canadians an
understanding of where we're at give
them a sense of the importance of our
continued support for for individuals
but also for our economy we've supported
people across the country we've given
them a bridge to the future and now we
need to think about how we get to that
that's safe restart and that is the that
is the period that we're in right now
you've extended the emergency benefits
like this herb once already are you
going to extend them again our approach
really has been very much about thinking
about how the various benefits we've put
in place can help us to get to the next
step so so we we see the the Serb
benefit as declining and importance
there's going to be fewer people on that
benefit but at the same time where we
are extending and making more important
the wage subsidy so helping
organizations to have the capacity to
hire back people as we have a safe
restart of the economy so do you think
we're now at a stage where we are
transitioning from this being an
emergency to sort of being a fact of
life that the pandemic is going to you
know has gone on for months will go on
for months more and that you need to
build that into your fiscal plans what
we're trying to do is to to build the
framework so we can move into that new
normal and that means thinking about the
things that we need to do together with
the provinces so we're we're in these
discussions right now we're thinking
about how do we get back to work so we
need to have childcare we need to have
sick leave so people could be off work
if they need to be municipalities need
to have support so they can have transit
systems to get people to work I wanted
to pick up on the point about childcare
and schools too because you know for
lots of parents with young kids
particularly women with young kids who
tend to do the bulk of the caregiving
they can't go back to work until there's
a place for the
kids is there something you're doing
specifically for them well it's the
reason the first thing I said Donna was
was child care is because we recognized
that challenge we are going to have to
work together with the provinces so
we've we've put out a 14 billion dollar
investment with the provinces we are
working through the approach in that in
that negotiation right now so we need to
think about that and it's it is as you
say inextricably linked to the school
system which again the provinces are
going to need to be working on you know
the NDP believe that the ultra-rich and
the big corporations are not paying
their fair share such as companies they
point out specifically Amazon and
Netflix who have made huge profits
during the pandemic because of the
pandemic
are you considering taxing them and
increasing taxes of the very rich this
has been something I've been working on
for a couple of years as Minister of
Finance we're working with the OECD to
try to get to an approach for the
taxation of those those huge Internet
giant's and we've made significant
progress I am you know cautiously
optimistic that we will get to an
approach that will make sure that
they're pairing paying their fair share
of taxes a final quick question we're
all anxious about the future what's
keeping you awake at night at the moment
for me I worry about jobs
first and foremost and getting the
economy of Hopman running means we have
jobs for people and that that to me is
the thing that allows the economy to
work to get us to new opportunities to
get us to growth so you know in the job
as Minister of Finance you have to worry
about a lot of things but having
Canadians working is is fundamental and
if we can get there you know we can get
through this challenge together Minister
Morneau thank you for your time
okay thank you and you can watch the
full interview on our website global
news dot CA / global national collapse
caught on camera next the moment in Nova
Scotia bridge falls into a river
you
well this bridge crossing didn't go as
planned it happened near canção nova
scotia the truck hauling a crane was
gingerly inching onto the bridge guided
by a man walking in front of it but they
didn't seem to factor in the weight of
that truck
one person is in the hospital for
observation the bridge was set to be
replaced this summer and crews were
moving in the equipment when this
happened we are watching a powerful
summer storm that's crossed over
Canada's largest city some of the
pictures from Toronto are wild a severe
thunderstorm watch is in place across
the city tonight
it has pounded that city with powerful
winds hail and sheets of torrential rain
there's flash flooding to causing a
hazard on a number of streets and that
is global national for this Wednesday
I'm Donna Friesen we leave you with a
much calmer seen in Waterton Lakes
National Park in southern Alberta we'd
love to see your Canada please email it
to viewers at global national calm
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow take care of yourselves
bye-bye
[Music]
[Applause]
you